the lawyer for foetus Doulos says he
will work to clear his clients name even
though Doulos is now dead
Otis doulos who had been charged with
killing his wife was taken off life
support yesterday on Tuesday police
found him unresponsive in his garage
after an apparent suicide attempt ola
legi reports on the note his lawyer says
he left behind mr. dillos was declared
dead at 5:32 after a struggle the
hospital had been satisfy itself that
there were was no opportunity to revive
him imagine all this came as a surprise
yes the death of foetus Doulos follows
an eight-month investigation into his
alleged involvement in the disappearance
of his estranged wife Jennifer there was
a note found next to him where police
discovered him unconscious Tuesday the
note that he left also declaring his
innocence so I'm told that nothing we've
heard from reliable sources that there
was a note saying I'm innocent my
lawyers concluded prosecutors accused
Doulos of killing Jennifer though her
body has never been found he's denied it
but on Tuesday police checked on him
after he failed to show up for a bond
hearing that could have sent him back to
jail mr. dillos was sitting in his
vehicle and he had obvious signs of
medical distress CBS News went inside
the home where officers broke through
this door to get in the garage where
police found two Lowe's
he was hospitalized for carbon monoxide
poisoning but later taken off life
support this wasn't the end we foresaw
the family has asked us to continue our
efforts and we will for CBS this morning
I'm Malou leggy